this video is brought to you by
squarespace the best way to make an
amazing website let's be honest is the
new 14-inch macbook pro really worth a
thousand dollars more than the m1
macbook air well today we will find out
because we are going to compare a bunch
of real world tasks such as regular
everyday use ssd speeds some different
benchmarks photo video editing battery
life speakers webcams and general stuff
that people do to see if it's worth
actually spending the money both of
these machines have a 100 battery so we
are going to unplug them and we know the
14-inch even they're amazing machines
they do suck more power so it's gonna be
interesting to see as we go through what
the battery life is like now i'm going
to go ahead and start out by comparing
the exterior differences because the m1
macbook air is this nice slim wedge
shape i loved the comfort and the
lightweightness of this machine only 2.8
pounds but the new 14 inch macbook pros
they have that square design that feels
a lot chunkier it's definitely heavier
the footprint is larger in both
dimensions and it is thicker as well
especially on the wedge edge and i gotta
say that i definitely prefer the design
and the slimness of the macbook air if
you care about portability it definitely
is a lot lighter and more convenient to
have with you now with that we also have
some differences on the bottom the 14
inch macbook pro has these cutouts on
the sides in the back because it does
have two fans whereas the m1 macbook air
is completely sealed because it's
completely fanless but with that said we
will actually test to see if we can even
hear the fans on the 14 inch or if it's
still silent a little bit later in the
test now talking about ports on the
left-hand side the macbook air only has
two thunderbolt ports whereas with the
14-inch we have those same two but their
thunderbolts four will have full display
support meaning they can actually
support two displays one through
thunderbolt and one on the other side
through hdmi whereas the macbook air can
only support one external display with
that you don't have to use one of those
ports to charge because we have magsafe
which is really nice and convenient and
then we have the headphone jack on the
left-hand side so it doesn't get in your
way if you're using a mouse on the other
side the macbook air just has a
headphone jack compared to an hdmi port
which is super convenient and an sd card
slot which means you don't need any
dongles along with that third
thunderbolt now before we open these up
i have to tell you guys about our
giveaway we're giving away one 2500 14
inch macbook pro it's not this one it's
a higher end one to one of you lucky
people out there all you have to do is
one be subscribed and two comment with
these launch week videos we're making
them up until tuesday one week from
launch and then we're choosing a winner
so make sure you guys come back every
day we post at 7am pacific check out our
videos and comment below and i don't
care if you're anywhere out there in the
world we will ship it to you we will pay
import taxes whatever it is and get one
of these in your hands and now let's
take a look at the insides the 14 inch
has full size function keys and then it
has a larger trackpad but to me that
really doesn't matter and the keyboard
feels identical on both so even though
we have this new look in either way it
doesn't make a real world difference now
what probably sticks out to you is the
notch yes macbooks now have a notch
we're gonna talk all about the displays
where we have a ton of differences in
just a sec but first i want to compare
the speakers the 14-inch now has a crazy
speaker system so let's see if we can
tell a difference
me
[Music]
all right guys wow what a difference the
macbook air already had one of the best
speakers in terms of ultrabooks but this
new 14 inch it just kills it we have
those dedicated woofers that move a ton
more air this year compared to the 16
inch setup last year so if you care
about movies or music with the built-in
speakers this one is the way to go it is
just incredible almost like adding a
subwoofer to your car now as far as the
webcams and microphones this is the
macbook air's 720p webcam which has
better processing due to m1 and it has
really good microphones as well but the
14-inch macbook pro has a 1080p webcam
with an f 2.0 aperture and it has
upgraded studio microphone so you guys
let me know which one looks better and
which one sounds better and how much of
a difference you see down in the
comments section below and now let's get
into the displays the new 14 inch has a
higher resolution display we have 6
million pixels compared to 4 million
but with that said i can't see a
noticeable difference to my eyes now
people have mentioned that you have two
times scaling just like on the imac so
it is easier on the eyes if you're
reading a lot of text but to me i don't
think that's a deal breaker both these
are 16 by 10 but because of the notch
apple actually added extra pixels where
we have that menu bar so you're not
really losing out on anything with the
notch and of course we have these nice
slim bezels all around now with that
said if you ever maximize a window and
application that notch gets hidden so
it's not distracting if you're doing
work or watching videos or anything like
that and as far as color accuracy the
latest m1 macbook airs also support dc
ip3 so if you're doing photo editing
video editing there's no difference in
terms of color grading and things like
that now yes the 14 inch does support
hdr content we're going to cover that in
just a sec but in terms of brightness
for regular use it is still limited to
500 nits instead of crazy a thousand or
1600 whereas the macbook air is limited
to 400 nits so you do have the
brightness difference that you guys can
see with our top camera but looking from
the side camera you guys can see that
the viewing angles are also a lot better
with the new 14-inch now when it comes
to playing back hdr photos or video you
guys can see the difference you don't
see the full thing because this is not a
hdr video for maximum compatibility but
look how much brighter the hdr mini led
screen that goes up to 1600 nits
on the 14 14-inch looks the highlights
pop like crazy not only that the
contrast is also better at the same time
so if you're watching hdr videos or
movies the experience is much better and
if you want to edit hdr video or even
hdr photos you need to have the 14 inch
now the new display can have some
blooming if you're watching in the dark
with the brightness maxed out with high
contrast text and things like that but
the macbook air has blooming across the
whole screen because it has a single
backlight and because of that and the
hdr screen it looks amazing for watching
movies in the dark the contrast levels
are pure black or as close as you can
get without oled but the brightness is
way better than oled and it makes for an
amazing movie watching experience
especially with those crazy speakers now
those aren't the only differences we
also have pro motion on the 14-inch
which means it can go up to 120 hertz
which makes everything super smooth in
the menus when you're scrolling and it's
great for gaming if you want to do some
of that but also it can go down to 24 to
save your battery life if you're
watching videos so let's be honest and
talk about does that screen matter that
much well right now i gotta say if
you're buying a 999 dollar macbook air
or actually for like 929 or maybe even
less on amazon we'll leave a link down
below that's a thousand dollar jump and
that makes it hard to justify
but if you're buying a macbook air with
16 gigs of ram and a 512 gig ssd just
like this 14 inch comes with for that 2
000 price that is a six hundred dollar
jump and then at that point that might
be enough to justify having this super
nice display along with the better
speakers and the other upgrades and that
display alone is just so amazing so it's
really up to you how much you care and
how much you watch videos if you can
make use of that now that we mentioned
ssds let's check out the speed
difference the m1 air was a big
improvement over the previous years we
have 2
100 right and 2
800 read but these new ones are insane
we have 4 600 rights and 4 800 almost
read so the ssds are basically twice as
fast compared to the air now does that
matter in the real world and i have to
say
no i don't think so it could matter if
you're buying the highest end new
macbooks and pushing them to the limits
but for regular use you don't really
notice the difference now before we get
into the performance test let me give a
shout out to the sponsor of this video
squarespace if you've been thinking
about making your own website
squarespace is seriously the best way to
go you can build a great looking website
like we did with literally no web making
experience it doesn't matter if you want
a portfolio a blog ecommerce or anything
else you just choose from one of their
great templates and easily customize it
it's incredibly simple it's affordable
and our sites have been running
flawlessly for years now bringing in
tons of traffic thanks to its built-in
seo tools start your free two-week trial
with no credit card required by going to
squarespace.com maxtec or by using the
custom link down below and when you're
ready to launch you will save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain and now let's get into
performance i'm going to start out with
geekbench 5 and the new 14 inch comes
with the m1 pro chip but for 2 000 you
actually get a binned version that comes
with an a core cpu only six of those are
high performance cores and a 14 core gpu
instead of a 16 core now our one
thousand dollar macbook air is also
binned but it's only missing one out of
eight graphics cores the cpu still has
four high performance cores so it's
gonna be interesting to see how these
compare now with that we're also gonna
do a video comparing the 14-inch bin
version compared to the unbind which
costs 300 more so make sure you guys
have those notifications enabled if you
guys want to see that along with other
videos like comparing 16 gigs of ram
compared to 32 and comparing 14 inch to
6 inch as far as thermal throttling all
of those videos are coming up all right
guys we have the scores and look at this
the single core is less than a one
percent difference almost identical and
that's what you're going to use
day-to-day simple tasks opening up
folders stuff like that you won't notice
a difference now as far as the
multi-core score we do have a difference
of 27 percent and that's what those two
extra performance scores get you with
the 14 inch and in just a bit we'll see
how that makes a difference in the real
world and now let's go ahead and test
out the graphics and compare the 14 core
bend compared to the 7 core and bam we
have our results and it looks like we're
from 18 800 to 35
400 so no going from 7 cores to 14 does
not exactly double the performance but
it is 88 better performance now the
other thing we have to keep in mind is
that the macbook air is fanless so
during an extended load we could have a
bigger difference and we'll check that
out in just a sec and now let's get into
gaming i have 3d marks new wildlife
extreme which is the latest to test
gaming performance with metal
acceleration and i'm going to use the
extreme unlimited mode let's go ahead
and get this started that is because
we're going to run this off screen to
make sure the resolution doesn't impact
the scores and promotion doesn't impact
anything and one thing that i want to
test is limitations for throttling
because we do have a fanless macbook air
here all right we have our scores and
the macbook air got 27.1 frames per
second compared to
55.5 so in this test if you're gaming we
literally get double the scaling just
slightly more than double the
performance while having double the
cores now when the test was running i
did not see any throttling for the
graphics the temperatures were fairly
low and of course the 14 inch will not
throttle but if you're doing very heavy
extended task with cpu and gpu use the
macbook air will throttle but
realistically it's not enough to make a
huge difference based on our test
compared to the other m1 max now
speaking of throttling i'm gonna test
out cinebench's throttle test it's gonna
run for 10 minutes and this is actually
a benchmark that is for 3d rendering if
you guys are interested in that it's
going to push the cpus to their limits
and of course the macbook air is fanless
now with the 14 inch it's been already a
minute of the test the fans are still
off so for most tasks that means that
even if it's short bursts of a hundred
percent the fans are gonna stay off now
i'm gonna let this run for another eight
or nine minutes until to the end and we
are gonna use my thermal camera to see
how hot does the macbook air get does
the bottom get super hot and how much
does it thermal throttle oh man it
literally just started spinning up the
fans and it's already been over two
minutes two minutes and 15 seconds
before the span fan spin up at all and
right now we don't have the exact cp
temperature but the hottest temperature
inside is showing
50 degrees celsius on the macbook air we
are looking like the cpu performance
cores are at 95 degrees and they have
been for what is it a couple minutes now
or about a minute
so it looks like yes right away on the
macbook air it does get hot and we'll
see the frequency at the end we are
almost done with the test and the
macbook air has been pinned at 95
degrees celsius the whole time and the
14 inch even though the fans are up
probably about a third of the way it is
still silent it cannot hear it over our
hvac system which is crazy and we don't
have the exact temps but the hottest
temp is at 56 degrees celsius now let's
go ahead and bust out my thermal camera
here we have a big hotspot where the
heatsink is at 44 degrees celsius the
macbook air is actually cooler at 40
degrees celsius for the hottest spot now
i also want to go ahead and pick this up
and take a look at the bottom of it
right there we have that big heat spot
at 40 degrees celsius of course our 14
inch has vents at the top so exhaust
here but the bottom is also at 40
degrees celsius at the hottest spot
meaning that if you care about the heat
on your lap we're not really seeing a
difference all right guys we are done
and i am shocked for one specific reason
first off let's talk about the scores we
have 6748
compared to
9506 so even though we saw a difference
of 27
in geekbench when we're pushing these to
the limit we have a difference of 40
percent and that is because of the
thermal throttling um so with the
macbook air after about halfway through
it's throttled all the way down to 2.35
gigahertz instead of 3.2 whereas the
macbook pro sticks at 3.2 gigahertz the
whole time now the reason why i'm
shocked is the fact that we literally
after 10 minutes of 100 cpu usage we
could not hear the fans this thing was
still silent so if you care about
silence there's no reason to go for the
macbook air if you can afford the 14
inch now what i want to do next is push
this machine to its limits because i
want to see if the fans can ever get
loud on it so i'm going to max out the
cpu right now i'm going to go back into
3dmark wildlife
and i'm going to go ahead and run that
extreme test as well so we're maxing out
both the cpu and we're maxing out the
graphics at the same time let's see what
happens with those fans all right guys
it's been two minutes of looping both
the cpu test and gpu being maxed out now
we can finally start to hear the fans
they're about 75 or so so that took
longer than expected to have those ramp
up and after two and a half minutes they
are completely maxed out and
really by the sound of it actually
actually go manually and enable those
and what's really surprising is that
even with the fans maxed out
they are not that loud what do you think
vadim was it 13 inch actually louder
than this maybe
so on all these days of testing we have
never had the fans get even like halfway
but when we force 100 for both cp and
gpu give it a few minutes it maxes out
and they're still pretty dang quiet that
is surprising now for those of you that
want to work with logic both of these
machines are excellent the m1 macbook
air can do about 88 tracks in the new
logic benchmark test you guys can find
all the details of the benchmark online
whereas the 14 inch base model it can
handle about 115
tracks with the same test so that's
about 30 percent more performance and
that kind of lines up with the cpu
differences now what i will say is for
logic if you're going to use a lot of
plug-ins you will want to upgrade the
macbook air to at least 16 gigs which is
actually the most you could do here
and if you're going to do a lot you have
the opportunity to go higher with the 14
inch and for those of you guys that want
to do some programming we are going to
test out xcode and thank you to max
airmenko for creating this benchmark for
us and this terminal command that
launches it bam and our results are in
and look at that we took
146 seconds for the m1 air and
110 seconds for the 14 inch bend model
that's a performance improvement of
about 32 percent now if that difference
is worth the money is going to be up to
you depending how often you compile code
but with that said even the m1 macbook
air is so much faster than past intel
models it is an insane difference so the
performance here is still excellent you
can actually download this online and
test out your system and what about if
you want to do a bit of 3d design is the
macbook air enough well i have the
latest version of blender that is
optimized for apple silicon and we are
going to go ahead and render this sample
project called party tug that you can
actually download on their website this
one actually uses metal so it's using
the graphics we'll see what difference
we get here all right that was really
fast our macbook air took 18.93 seconds
almost 19 seconds compared to 9.73
so the 14 inch with the 14 core graphics
is almost twice as fast which you would
expect and both of these are actually
extremely fast for a tough scene like
this because of their unified memory
compared to older intel processors so
once again you can download this make
sure it's completely pre-loaded before
you render and compare these systems to
yours and now for the photo editors i
have adobe lightroom over here and i
have to say that real world performance
is slightly quicker on the 14-inch not a
huge difference but you might have a
little bit smoother brushes now the
other thing we have here is eight gigs
ram versus 16 and ram does help for
photo editing especially when you're
doing batch processing so i would say if
you do a lot of that you do want 16 gigs
of ram and now let's go ahead and run an
export test i have 50 42 megapixel raw
images here all graded ready to go out
to jpeg so let's see how long it's gonna
take now check this out guys while this
is running look how much ram is being
used on the eight gig macbook we have
six and a half gigs of ram out of eight
used but another 6 gigs of swap meaning
it's writing files to the ssd and of
course the ssd even though it's super
fast it's not as fast as the 14 inch now
on this one we have 16 gigs and 14 gigs
out of those 16 are being used and we're
still using swap memory to the crazy
fast ssd so both of these would like to
have more ram if we had it available and
it would speed stuff up a little bit now
as i may have mentioned we are going to
be doing a 16 gig versus 2 32 gig video
soon so make sure you guys check out
that video bam we are finished and our
macbook air took two minutes and 46
seconds and then the 14 inch macbook pro
took a minute and 42 seconds that is
63
faster and that's interesting because
the cpu difference is what 30 or so now
that is because one we have the extra
ram but even more important than that
this is using 16 channel memory uh so
has twice the bandwidth and that also
helps meaning if you get 16 gigs on this
one it might be about 20 30 seconds
faster but it will not be as quick as a
new macbook pros now of course in the
real world unless you're somebody that's
editing 50 100 photos a day or a
thousand like a wedding photographer you
can wait a little bit longer and you
know have the export take longer it's
not that big of a deal but it could add
up enough to wanting to spend the extra
and now for the video editors we are
going to test out final cut pro for the
footage that most people work with which
is h.264 both these machines do
incredibly well in final cut and also in
davinci resolve and i've been using the
m1 macbook air for almost a year now
editing a ton of my videos because most
of it it can handle right now i have two
lots of plied and film grain and it's
running just fine now the issue comes in
if you end up doing tougher footage or
stacking even more effects which we'll
show you but the first thing that i want
to do is an export test with this new m1
pro chip let's start the export and hit
our timer as you might be able to see
with the m1 air our graphics are at 98
they are maxed out compared to only 64
on the 14 inch that is because with this
machine the encoders are limiting the
export not the cpu or the gpu whereas
with the macbook air we don't have
enough graphics performance to go any
faster but as you guys can see the
export times are very very close and
that is because projects like these even
with a couple luts and a film grain
applied
they're not that difficult so don't
think if you spend the extra money you
automatically will have faster speeds if
you do want the fastest export speeds
you have to buy the m1 max chip which
has double the encoders meaning it could
go up to twice as fast for something
like this but then you got to ask
yourself if it's worth paying at least 2
900 for that and the times are 255 and
308 so it's only a 13 second difference
now you could export this project to
h.265 and then both would be a lot
faster about half the time for this test
but once again this one the 14 inch will
still be a little bit quicker now the
real difference comes in if we are
working with tougher projects i'm gonna
export this red raw project and the
macbook air took two minutes and 32
seconds for only a one minute project
compared to one minute and 28 seconds so
that's a difference of about 73 faster
even though we're still exporting h.264
so we have those encoders there because
of the much higher graphics load we see
that 73 difference instead of just a
seven percent difference so if you
really start pushing the macbook air
that's when it's really going to start
slowing down and the last thing i have
to mention is prores or pro vs raw
footage even though they are smooth for
both once you start adding effects the
m1 air will start getting limited and
then if we go and export a project the
14 inch macbook pro absolutely flies
through it it's already at what 40 right
here compared to just 10
and that is because it has dedicated
decoders and encoders for prores and
prores raw so if you're somebody that
works with these codecs i would
definitely think about investing the
extra money for a 14 inch wow right
there the 14 inch just got done took a
minute and seven seconds where this one
was only at 25
in that time meaning it takes about four
and a half minutes to export a
five-minute project still fast but
nothing like the 14-inch and now let's
talk about battery life we've been
testing for multiple hours now how long
maybe three hours or so
three four hours let's take a look at
the battery life on the m1 macbook air
we are at 44
battery and on the 14 inch we're at 46
now how does that make sense when the 14
inch takes so much more power for its
display and more powerful cpu and
graphics well first off its battery is
40
larger compared to that macbook air and
second along with that even though it
uses more power it did a lot of those
benchmarking tasks much quicker while we
had to sit and wait for the macbook air
and before we got into benchmarks the
macbook air was actually leading in
battery life so what this means is for a
really easy simple task even though the
battery is smaller than the macbook air
it still will give you maybe one to two
hours battery battery life for web
browsing email maybe watching some
videos but if you start doing tougher
tasks like gaming photo editing video
editing coding that kind of the stuff
you will still get better battery life
with the 14 inch macbook pro so if you
were worried about battery life do not
worry with this new macbook now before
we give our final verdict i want to give
a shout out to our merch this is the m1x
hoodie now we did do the sharpie edition
for the shirt and i think we have one
for the hoodie as well right vadim
sharpie edition we do have one we just
don't have a silver sharpie but if
you've made it this far if you guys
enjoy our videos go and check out our
merch we have a lot of great designs and
you can use the promo code m1 pro for 20
off for a limited time we would greatly
appreciate it and of course if you
haven't yet subscribed go ahead and
subscribe comment below so you guys can
win a 2500
14 inch macbook pro and if you don't
care about winning do it to help us
reach our goal of 1 million subscribers
before the end of the year we would
greatly appreciate it and with that said
what is the final verdict let's answer
the original question is the m1 macbook
air good enough or is it worth spending
a thousand dollars more for the 14 inch
well as we guys showed you all the
differences you get a lot more for the
money you get extra ports extra displays
a much nicer screen much nicer speakers
you're getting a lot for the money but
if you don't push him hard to use simple
tasks the m1 macbook air is much lighter
you'll get better battery life and
you're saving so much cash you can
literally buy one as a gift for a friend
or family member and even if you start
doing photo and video editing and you're
not doing extreme stuff in coding and
logic it still does such an amazing job
so for most people unless you're going
to the extremes with productivity the m1
macbook air is enough it's just mainly
do you want the extra updated features
new design new display that kind of
stuff so if you want to save some money
get yourself the m1 macbook air we
actually have links below to amazon they
have great sales on there right now i
think it was 929
to pick one up i don't think you will be
disappointed so don't feel like you are
missing out so there you guys go there
is our full comparison thank you guys
for watching click that circle above to
subscribe once again we have a couple
great videos right over there that's
been max and i will see you in the next
video
[Music]